what uh advice would you give to let's
start with a complete beginner
so
um you know a bunch of people come up to
me they still want to start doing Jiu
Jitsu what advice would you give them
try to absorb as much technique as you
can and try to be as relaxed as you can
don't
you know don't desperately try to
fight so hard
like learn
and move slow
move slow and relax that's the hardest
thing to do
yeah how does you know you know what I
find with people it seems like it's hard
to even know that you're not relaxed
it's it's like the introspection
they don't even know what it feels like
to relax not even know they tense yeah
right they're trying to relax you look
at you see what what do you mean relax
I'm relaxed exactly exactly
you feel it and in terms of going slow
they're like yeah where I'm going slow
no you're you're not yeah uh yeah
there's there's a there's a grace and
elegance of movement that you can
probably pick up from a lot of other
disciplines like for me I think that
came from just learning piano piano at a
young age this for um I think any
Mobility thing to learn how to move
efficiently you have to know how to
relax it's just the fact that you can
like the body can be tense so it could
be relaxed just knowing that fact now
imagine you showed the stints yeah play
piano well no yeah everything has to be
relaxed I guess some of that is mind too
but just knowing that and being
self-aware and you but see like even me
um
you know approaching a thing I'm not
I don't know anything about being a
beginner you're going to tense up no
matter and like it actually takes a
conscious effort to think to relax I
mean that's massively that's why
learning things as an adult is much
harder than as a child like it's very
hard and as an adult
it's like to get to the highest level
it's not possible
because you will never relax
food the way you should yeah relax in a
way that you become like water but then
you solidify in the right places